la cour criminelle une toute nouvelle
juridiction pour les crimes dont la
peine encourue est inférieur ou égal à
20 ans ce sont les viols les vols avec
armes ou encore les homicides
involontaires
finie la cour d'assises pour juger ces
crimes place à la cour criminelle
la différence le jury populaire ni
siègera pas content vous avez des
personnes qui ne connaissent rien au
droit qui sont tirés au sort et à qui on
dit vous allez venir dans une
juridiction et vous allez juger les
faits les plus graves
bien évidemment qu'il faut un temps
important d'explication et le président
de la cour d'assises ses assesseurs
devait très souvent faire des
suspensions d'audience pour expliquer
aux jurés ce qui s'était passé pour voir
un petit peu comment es tu avais compris
pour être sûr qu'ils avaient compris ce
qui se passait au cours au cours des
débats
un temps nécessaire certes mais trop
important alors la solution est toute
trouvée exit les jurés tirés au sort
ils seront remplacés par cinq magistrats
il n'a pas été question de rayer
complètement de la carte le jury
populaire simplement de rechercher une
meilleure méthode à meilleur moyen de
juger les affaires criminelles puisqu'on
a fait le constat france entière que
dans certains ressorts on juge mal les
affaires criminelles
parce qu'on est trop de temps à les
juger mais les jurés ne disparaissent
pas pour autant si le verdict de la cour
criminelle n'est pas satisfaisant les
parties pourront toujours faire appel et
en cour d'appel
le jury populaire siègera mais dans ces
sept départements
l'objectif de la cour criminelle c'est
bien la réduction des délais de jugement
on nous l'a présenté comme une réforme
tendant à alléger la procédure et à
l'accélérer pour permettre à certaines
cures engorgé d'aller plus vite et
d'ailleurs on impose notamment lorsque
les accusés sont détenus d'aller plus
vite
en termes de délais on a un besoin jeu
et sinon nous avons une cour d'assises
qui fonctionne parfaitement n'avons pas
de retard nous allons les délais
d'audiencement tout à fait raisonnable
donc on n'a pas ce besoin comme
connaissent d'autres cours
l'idée à bourges c'est d'expérimenter
cette nouvelle juridiction et d'en tirer
les conséquences dans une cour qui
fonctionne correctement premier procès
le 8 octobre une affaire de viol sur
plusieurs mineurs de moins de 15 ans